hey 42 here humans kill at least a
hundred million sharks a year or about
eleven thousand an hour welcome to RIT
if everyone in the world washed their
hands properly a million lives could be
saved a year the Pentagon has actually
created an emergency plan in case of a
zombie attack Steve Jobs held important
business meetings whilst walking because
our brains work better whilst a body is
physically active a Blackpool hotel
charged a couple a 100 pound fine after
they wrote a TripAdvisor review
describing it as a dirty rotten stinking
hovel run by Muppets queen elizabeth ii
of england owns a drive-through
mcdonald's as part of her enormous
property portfolio to help panda cubs
adapt to living in the wild researchers
at a panda center in china work panda
costumes while working with them male
kangaroos are known to flex their biceps
to impress female kangaroos most bees
buzz in the key of a unless they are
tired when they buzz in the key of 8 in
2011 a woman bought a non-visible piece
of art for ten thousand dollars entitled
fresh air mr. cans Oh is a popular
Japanese restaurant that only serves
tinned food diners get to select their
meal from a huge variety of tinned food
from the shelves a woman who survived
the plane bomb explosion in 1972 was
awarded the Guinness World Record title
for the highest fall without a parachute
at 33,000 feet women by 85% of the
world's Valentine's cards and 90
6% of all the candles in America Honda
eat bamboo for at least 12 hours a day
the Indonesian volcano kawah ijen
produces blue flames from its lava
because of its high sulfur content a
single human male produces enough sperm
in a fortnight to impregnate every
fertile woman on the planet thanks for
the view subscribe for more thoughty2